[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen un recorrido a lo
largo de la semana con los principales
temas los más destacados en relación a
la pandemia de kobe 19 en nuestro
continente soy santiago lópez gonzález y
a continuación les presento el sumario
de tema que tenemos para hoy vamos a
comenzar en eeuu porque este país superó
la barrera de las 200.000 víctimas por
cuenta de la pandemia del cob y 19
florida texas california wisconsin e
illinois son los estados con la mayor
cantidad de casos tenemos reportes desde
la ciudad de miami precisamente en el
estado de florida en la ciudad de
yaroslav en rusia allí avanza el
desarrollo y la investigación por la
vacuna es public b que fue ofrecida por
el presidente ruso vladimir putin para
que sea distribuida en todo el mundo de
manera gratuita conversamos con
sebastián beltrame o vamos a conversar
con sebastián beltrame él es un
periodista uruguayo que visitó este
laboratorio y conoció en detalle de
primera mano cómo está avanzando el
desarrollo de esta posible vacuna y cuál
es la expectativa que hay allí
el carnaval de río de janeiro una de las
más importantes y tradicionales fiestas
de brasil fue suspendido por primera vez
en 108 años por causa de la pandemia
nuestra corresponsal nos contará cómo
impacta esto no solo en el ánimo de los
brasileños sino también en la economía
de la ciudad de río de janeiro
comenzamos y antes de dar paso a la
información primero vamos a hacer un
recuento de cómo avanzó en la pandemia
del cob y 19 a lo largo de esta semana
en nuestra región demos un vistazo a los
países de américa latina con más
fallecidos por cada millón de habitantes
en primer lugar vemos en rojo está perú
este país suramericano tiene más de 998
víctimas por millón
le sigue el anaranjado su vecina bolivia
con 705 en tercer lugar está brasil con
668 casos o víctimas por millón de
habitantes ecuador con 659 y cierra este
top en amarillo chile con 659 por cada
millón de habitantes le siguen en su
estricto orden estados unidos-méxico
colombia y argentina
esta semana el mundo entero vio con
alarma el anuncio eeuu superó las
200.000 víctimas fallecidas a por kobe
19 el país sigue siendo el más afectado
a nivel mundial por la pandemia
esta cifra supera así la suma total de
estadounidenses fallecidos en 5 guerras
recientes como la guerra de vietnam
corea e irak de afganistán y la guerra
del golfo pérsico eeuu también superó
esta semana los 7 millones de casos
diagnosticados vamos a conocer detalles
de lo que está sucediendo allí con
anthony welsch y el corresponsal de
france 24 en la ciudad de miami para
conocer allí más detalles anthony más de
200.000 víctimas más de 7 millones de
casos diagnosticados que dicen las
autoridades al respecto particularmente
allí en la florida que es donde usted se
encuentra
pues sí quedan muy buenas noches son
cifras realmente preocupantes de esos
200.000 fallecidos son más de 7 millones
de casos positivos de kobe de 19 y las
autoridades en médicas sobre todo están
pidiendo a la población no bajar la
guardia sobre todo ahora que van a
empezar a bajar las temperaturas con la
temporada de invierno y va a coincidir
también con la temporada de la gripe por
lo que seguro dicen en los expertos en
médicos van a coincidir tanto el
coronavirus como lakovic 19 pero estamos
muy pendientes en estados como florida
nueva york california o texas donde se
han dado los casos más elevados de kobe
19 pues cómo se va avanzando esta
pandemia de hecho aquí en el sur del
estado de florida el gobernador
republicano ron de santis ha anunciado
esta misma tarde que va a suavizar todas
las medidas del coronavirus eso que
quiere decir que todos los negocios van
a poder haber
al cien por cien de su capacidad y el
uso de mascarillas no va a ser
obligatorio antonio tal parece que la
comunidad internacional le preocupan más
estas cifras porque lo que uno ve en las
imágenes y en los reportes es que los
estadounidenses le están restando un
poco de importancia a las medidas de
seguridad y están empezando a llevar su
vida con total normalidad cuál es la
reacción de la población allí en florida
con respecto a estos números que son
alarmantes
si realmente esa actitud de nuevo ha
cambiado desde el inicio de la pandemia
cuando secreto el estado de alarma
nacional aquí en eeuu cientos de
personas salieron a las calles
prácticamente desde la primera semana a
protestar por las medidas que se estaban
implantando decían que todo era una
farsa que realmente en los casos y en
los fallecimientos no eran tan
alarmantes y eso se comparaban con otras
otras enfermedades como el caso de la
gripe que sí que hay vacuna y que sí que
en esos momentos el ratio de
fallecimientos era más elevado pedían a
las autoridades suavizar las medidas
porque querían ir a trabajar ya que de
no hacerlo no podían ganar dinero y no
podían mantener a su familia por eso
sorprendía esta actitud de muchísimos a
estadounidenses que pues intentaban
desafiar las órdenes de las autoridades
para no utilizar mascarillas en ni
tampoco respetar la distancia social
algo que están pidiendo a las
autoridades sanitarias
es aquí en el país antonio para terminar
este reporte qué tal está avanzando
entonces la reapertura social pues ya lo
veíamos que los estadounidenses lo están
tomando un poco más relajado que en
otros países pero cómo va la reapertura
económica la reapertura de los comercios
de los bares de los restaurantes está
terminando el verano y pues empieza una
nueva temporada
que es particularmente fuerte dada las
nevadas y las condiciones en el norte
del país
y realmente está por ver qué es lo que
va a pasar a partir de ahora hay que
recordar que las fronteras están
parcialmente cerradas en eeuu no se
puede volar desde no se puede recibir
turismo desde europa y desde otros
países como también brasil donde se
están registrando un número muy elevado
de casos de coronavirus y por eso aquí
los comerciantes en el sur de la florida
sobre todo que se dedican principalmente
al turismo están preocupados llevan más
de seis meses sin poder trabajar sin
poder recibir el turismo y ese golpe a
la economía podría ser brutal además
también está por ver de qué manera va a
afectar esa nueva normativa que ha
impulsado el gobernador ron de santis
para todo el estado ya que las
autoridades locales como por ejemplo
aquí en la ciudad de miami pues podrían
poner en medidas mucho más restrictivas
el posible aumento de los casos de
coronavirus pero está por ver cómo va
avanzando esta pandemia aunque los
expertos financieros aseguran que el
golpe económico no va a tener
precedentes
antonio es que no hay economía que
aguante está completamente cerrada más
de seis meses sin tener ganancias ni
hacer la inversiones muchas gracias por
este reporte desde la ciudad de miami en
el estado de la florida y no muy lejos
de allí en méxico las cifras tampoco dan
tregua este país contabiliza más de 700
mil casos y tiene también el poco
honroso primer lugar en américa latina
por ser la nación que presenta la mayor
cantidad de muertes del personal
sanitario por cuenta de kobe 19 varió
carbone el corresponsal de france 24
está con nosotros desde la ciudad de
mexico y vamos a consultarle cómo está
la situación allí mario buenas noches
gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de kobe 19 la semana en américa y ayer
tal parece que se rompió la tendencia de
vida
lo que ha sucedido a lo largo de esta
semana y baja ese porcentaje que daba un
respiro en cuanto a las cifras de
contagio de víctimas
ayer hubo un ligero repunte que lo que
está pasando
así es se informó de un alza de un
repunte en el porcentaje de positividad
algo que no ocurría desde la última
semana de julio donde pues empezó esta
tendencia a la baja y desafortunadamente
en las últimas 24 horas se reportó este
repunte de 37 a 39 por ciento de
positividad acaban de salir hace unos
instantes las cifras más recientes son
más de 720 mil contagios en el país y
más de 75 mil 800 muertes por
coronavirus la situación es distinta en
cada estado santiago mira en la ciudad
de mexico donde se da el mayor número de
contagios la jefa de gobierno anunció
este día que estamos ya en el punto más
bajo de la pandemia de la capital del
país desde abril es decir hay 3500
personas hospitalizadas en el valle de
mexico
contando la ciudad de mexico y el estado
de mexico y esto
a la capital que insisto es la ciudad
con más casos de muertes y de contagios
más cerca de lo que es el semáforo
amarillo sin embargo no se echan las
campanas al vuelo' se establece que van
a reforzarse las visitas a los hogares
donde se tiene identificados casos de
contagios casos positivos
identificar a los contactos y hacer un
trabajo mejor de contención la jefa de
gobierno dijo que está baja en la ciudad
en el caso de la ciudad ha sido posible
gracias a que los ciudadanos han llevado
a cabo las medidas recomendadas sobre
todo el uso de cubrebocas en lugares
públicos que es pues un asunto que a
nivel federal ha tenido ciertas
reticencias para recomendarla así tal
como es el uso de cubrebocas
méxico tiene la pandemia un poco dispara
hay unos estados que están con
características y con avances de la
pandemia de forma diferente
ciudad de mexico el estado de mexico de
acuerdo al último reporte van a mantener
esto del semáforo en color anaranjado se
mantiene entonces unas medidas pero los
estados de campeche y de chiapas que
están en el sur pasan a color verde qué
significa esto y que otros ejemplos nos
puede dar de este semáforo de cómo van
evolucionando entonces allí las cosas
así es son sobre todo los estados de
menor población pero también los estados
que desde el inicio de la pandemia han
tenido un comportamiento de contención
es el caso como bien lo mencionas de
chiapas también de algunos otros estados
como quintana roo en donde campeche por
ejemplo donde ya este paso al semáforo
verde inminente que implica bueno
implica que ya se puede volver con las
actividades de manera normal incluidas
en las clases presenciales no obstante
hay que señalar que es una facultad de
cada estado en el caso por ejemplo de
chiapas y campeche el propio presidente
de lópez obrador dijo que podría
consultarse a los padres de familia si
están de acuerdo en que se vuelva ya a
las clases presenciales el propio
gobernador de campeche ha dicho que no
que ellos descartan que seguirán
manteniendo está sana distancia social
digámoslo así está este aislamiento
parcial a pesar de que ya podrían volver
a las clases se han estado abierto
abriendo otros otros sectores de la
economía por ejemplo el más reciente
aquí en la capital son los gimnasios ya
la gente puede acudir a los gimnasios a
hacer ejercicio no cardiovascular pero
sí de peso integrado si las albercas sin
embargo hay mucha cautela santiago no no
se quiere dar el paso de vuelta completa
a la normalidad se prefiere en el caso
de la ciudad mantener este semáforo en
naranja también en el estado de mexico y
bueno el propio secretario de educación
esteban moctezuma ha dicho que aquellos
padres que no quieran llevar a sus hijos
a la escuela a un semáforo verde pueden
continuar con las clases por televisión
pues vamos a ver cómo se van
desarrollando estas medidas que semana a
semana van cambiando sobre todo allí en
méxico que es un país federal entonces
cada estado toma algunas de sus
decisiones mário muchas gracias por este
reporte por este completo reporte de
todo lo que aconteció en mexico a lo
largo de esta semana en muchas gracias
vamos a avanzar con otros temas
kóvacs
el nombre de una red recientemente
puesta en marcha a la que pertenecen
varios países que han unido sus
esfuerzos para el desarrollo de la
producción y también la distribución
equitativa de una vacuna contra el cubil
19 la iniciativa fue presentada por la
organización mundial de la salud que
indicó que ya son 156 los países que van
a pertenecer o que ya pertenecen a esta
iniciativa china y eeuu son los grandes
ausentes
156 países se han unido para garantizar
que todas las naciones del mundo tengan
acceso a la vacuna contra el coronavirus
al mismo tiempo el director de la
organización mundial de la salud hizo el
anuncio ahora en mistura nuestro
objetivo es tener 2000 millones de dosis
de vacunas disponibles para finales de
2021 nos alienta a ver que un gran
número de países se inscriben en la red
de kóvacs pero enfrentamos algunos
desafíos abrumadores para que esto
funcione según lo planeado debe haber
financiación y tertsch work as plan it
must be fánder
la lista de países que harán parte de la
red kóvacs incluye 64 naciones de
ingresos medios o altos que participarán
en la financiación de la vacuna entre
ellos los de la unión europea japón
australia argentina perú y colombia pero
los grandes ausentes son eeuu y china
el primero se desvinculó este año de la
ms una decisión tomada por el presidente
de donald trump mientras que los
funcionarios de la alianza siguen en
diálogos con beijing la o&m se aseguró
que por ahora se han invertido 3 mil
millones de dólares sin embargo es
apenas una pequeña parte de los 35 mil
millones de dólares necesarios para que
tenga el impacto que se espera en perú
uno de los países más afectados por el
virus al tener la mayor tasa de
mortalidad por cada 100.000 habitantes
el presidente martín vizcarra aseguró
que el mundo entero debe tener acceso a
la futura vacuna
y ello exige unirnos en esta lucha de
forma efectiva reconociendo a la vacuna
y el tratamiento contra este virus como
bienes públicos globales y asegurando el
acceso oportuno y equitativo a
medicamentos y equipos necesarios para
tumbarlo los casos de coronavirus en
todo el mundo han superado ya los 31
millones de personas y el número de
muertos se acerca al millón
la vacuna sputnik es una vacuna
vectorial combinada contra el
coronavirus que está siendo estudiada y
desarrollada por el gamma leia research
institute actualmente está en fase 3 y
hay mucho escepticismo a nivel
internacional con esta vacuna dada la
rapidez con la que fue anunciada y su
efectividad y también porque el
presidente ruso vladimir putin dijo que
de comprobarse su eficacia se la daría
gratis al mundo entero
sebastián beltrame es un periodista
uruguayo y es el único periodista de
américa latina- que ha podido ir a una
de las sedes de este laboratorio en la
ciudad de yaroslav a unos 250 kilómetros
de la ciudad de moscú la capital rusa y
está con nosotros ahora desde la ciudad
de montevideo la capital uruguaya para
contarnos cuáles fueron sus impresiones
y qué es lo que están desarrollando y
trabajando allí en este laboratorio
buenas noches sebastián gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france 24 y
cuéntanos cuáles fueron esas impresiones
de esa visita a ese laboratorio en la
ciudad de yaroslav qué fue lo que usted
encontró allí
buenas noches
en primer lugar fuimos los primeros
latinoamericanos en entrar a russia rus
ya está cerrada no podemos acceder
normalmente y fuimos los primeros no
rusos los primeros extranjeros en tener
acceso en todo el mundo a los
laboratorios del instituto gamal ella
las fábricas que producen la vacuna no
solamente producen la vacuna estas
fábricas por ejemplo también producen
medicamentos contra el coronavirus como
por ejemplo el abrir un medicamento que
últimamente está bastante siendo
bastante nombrado porque rusia lo está
suministrando a muchos países de
latinoamérica y se ha convertido además
en el principal medicamento contra el
coronavirus que exporta rusia nuestra
impresión al recorrer los laboratorios y
al estar en la fábrica los laboratorios
tengamos en cuenta que el instituto
gamal ella tiene más de 100 años y es un
instituto que ha desarrollado vacunas
se están utilizando desde hace mucho
tiempo y en base a esas vacunas es que
ellos afirman haber hecho la digamos el
proceso previo de estudio y desarrollo
de esta vacuna sputnik be contra el kobe
19 tiene la base por ejemplo de otras
como la del ébola y es por eso que ellos
afirman
ha sido muy rápido el desarrollo porque
ya contaban con todos esos estudios
previos de las vacunas anteriores
entonces utilizando
justamente esa tecnología es que han
desarrollado esta vacuna el escepticismo
en el mundo fue justamente porque se
dice que apareció de la nada
que nadie la tenía en cuenta incluso la
organización mundial de la salud no
nombraba a rusia entre los países que
venían desarrollando la vacuna mi
impresión particular al estar ahí
a los rusos son tan grandes como país
que muchas veces pecan de centrarse en
su propia producción
no
y mostrar lo que están haciendo hacia el
mundo esa es mi impresión personal al
haber estado dentro de los laboratorios
y noté que los científicos que están
trabajando ahí a los cuales se
entreviste de directores y los mismos
científicos que están desarrollando una
vacuna están trabajando en el día a día
para ellos es su trabajo y me pareció
que no tenían
no se daban cuenta de la importancia de
lo que estaban desarrollando justamente
porque lo que hacen todos los días
entonces lo que hay adentro es un
trabajo con mucho desarrollo
y que a mi entender no sé no sé mostró
al resto del mundo cómo se debería haber
mostrado del inprés precisamente de
sebastián por esa parte le quería
preguntar qué datos conoció a usted en
torno a esa posible colaboración
internacional que puede haber entre este
laboratorio el gobierno ruso y una
posible venta o distribución de esta
vacuna dado el caso que llegue a ser
exitosa y que llegue a estar dentro de
las posibles vacunas para que para
terminar esta vacuna esta pandemia del
cobi 19
es importante aclarar que todas las
vacunas van a pasar por estos procesos
por las distintas fases rusia ya está en
la fase 3
yo llegué hace pocos días de moscú y
cuando salí de moscú ya hacía una semana
que rusia estaba vacunando a la
población llevaban más de entre 5 y 10
mil personas con la vacuna están dando
la vacuna y una parte de esa población
recibe un placebo ese es el ensayo de la
fase 3 el ensayo en población y pensaban
llegar en poco tiempo a las 40.000
personas o sea que están avanzando muy
rápido si el responsable de la
financiación y de la comercialización o
el acuerdo con los distintos países para
en el caso de que la vacuna pase todas
las fases y se apruebe
el fondo directo de inversión rusa que
es el que financia la vacuna y que hace
estos acuerdos y ese ese fondo el que ya
está negociando con diferentes países
incluso de latinoamérica para la
o el envío de la vacuna o la posible
producción de la vacuna si fuera de
rusia en algún país de latinoamérica de
cuba es uno de estos países que ya ha
hecho acercamientos con el gobierno ruso
para ser uno de los países donde se
fabrique estaba ponencia pueda
distribuir sebastián el término por
preguntarle por su viaje hasta rusia
porque uruguay es el único país de
américa latina que tiene permitido a sus
ciudadanos viajar a la unión europea
usted entró por españa al continente
europeo y desde allí llegó
posteriormente a rusia ahora españa está
en un escenario otra vez apocalíptico
con la cantidad de casos que se está
presentando cómo fue esa experiencia de
viaje en plena pandemia y cómo fue esos
tránsitos por los aeropuertos españoles
para llegar hasta moscú
bueno la
todo surgió porque nosotros queríamos
mostrar cómo era hoy viajar en esta
situación entonces si uruguay es el
único país de américa que no tiene
ningún tipo de restricción para entrar
en el espacio schengen básicamente la
comunidad económica europea y los vuelos
montevideo-madrid directos no exigen a
los pasajeros ni test de psr de comida
ni
cuarentena al llegar entonces en esa
situación pues muy sencillo volar hacia
españa
me encontré personalmente con una españa
diferente en distintos lugares barcelona
un lugar donde prácticamente las calles
en la zona turística de las ramblas
estaban vacías muchos comercios cerrados
porque los turistas no están entrando a
españa sobre todo porque países
dotaban de turismo a españa este a este
país exigen cuarentena al volver
entonces las personas no quieren viajar
hacia españa pero por ejemplo en madrid
si no te de mucho movimiento
es más
salimos a comer a cenar la gente
manteniendo las medidas respectivas pero
hace una vida relativamente normal si en
españa es obligatorio el uso de
mascarillas de tapabocas las 24 horas en
exterior y en interior
eso se nota permanentemente hay multas
muy fuertes de unos cien euros para el
que no la use no hay hasta el momento no
había hasta el momento que estuve
restricciones del tipo de que nadie
tenía que quedarse en su casa todo el
mundo hacía vida básicamente normal lo
que sí es importante es que yo
entrevisté personalmente a algunas
personas
trabajaban en la salud en españa
y me decían que si bien los rebrotes de
coronavirus son mayores también es
porque antes de españa no hacía tests
psr a la población ahora se masificaron
entonces si aparecen más casos pero el
sistema de salud español está más
preparado por lo tanto la relación entre
los infectados y la muerte es mucho
menor que al principio y como llegamos a
rusia tuvimos que hacer una odisea
básicamente triangulamos a través de
turquía porque los vuelos de españa
hacia rusia no existe y en muchos países
también están cortados así que tuviesen
que hacer esa triangulación para llegar
sebastián beltrame muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en
france24 habernos contado esta
experiencia el único periodista
latinoamericano que ha llegado hasta las
hasta el laboratorio que está fabricando
está desarrollando esta posible vacuna
de coronavirus en rusia muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotras ya sea
ustedes vamos ahora con más datos más
noticias de lo que ha sucedido en
américa
los organizadores del carnaval de río de
janeiro anunciaron la suspensión de este
evento para el año 2021 debido a la
pandemia el carnaval es una de las
tradiciones culturales más arraigadas en
el imaginario de los brasileños además
de ser también una festividad muy
reconocida en el mundo entero la
suspensión trae consecuencias a todo
nivel
valeria saccone nos cuenta más en su
reporte desde río de janeiro
decisión histórica noche en río de
janeiro se aplaza el carnaval del
sambódromo por razones de seguridad
debido a la pandemia de coronavirus la
decisión de la liga de las escuelas de
samba fue unánime y no se ofreció a una
fecha alternativa porque dicen sin una
previsión de vacuna es imposible
organizar lo que ellos definen como la
fiesta más grande del planeta hay que
recordar que este año al principio del
año se batieron todos los récords más de
10 millones entre visitantes y turistas
casi el 100% de los hoteles ocupados y
725 millones de dólares de facturación
todo esto se ve suspendido también en
otras ciudades por ejemplo sant pau lo
tomó la misma decisión en julio está
barajando celebrar el carnaval
en junio sin embargo no se sabe todavía
hay que decir que san paolo en los
últimos años había superado un numerosa
río de janeiro pero obviamente río de
janeiro es la fiesta más importante de
todo el continente y hay que recordar un
episodio histórico muy interesante a
principio del siglo pasado dos veces por
razones diferentes fue suspendido el
carnaval oficial y río de janeiro
celebró un carnaval extraoficial en la
fecha prevista y otro en la nueva fecha
o sea en aquellos años hubo dos
carnavales incluso después de la gripe
española entre 1918 y 1920 hubo unos
carnavales muy locos en los que la gente
literalmente se echó a la calle para
disfrutarlo entonces es muy probable que
el río de janeiro veremos alguna forma
de carnaval espontáneo porque si hay
algo que el río no se puede perder la
gente es una buena fiesta y seguimos en
brasil el segundo país con la mayor
cantidad de víctimas por el coronavirus
las favelas o los barrios menos
favorecidos
y ha habido pocos diagnósticos de esta
enfermedad pero conocimos la historia de
una fisioterapeuta que brinda algunos
tratamientos gratis para quienes la han
padecido en los suburbios del norte del
río de janeiro el grupo de favelas
complexo do alemao no se ha librado de
la pandemia en el laberinto de
callejones el virus aún se está
propagando mónica fisioterapeuta volvió
a trabajar hace dos meses tan pronto
como llegó a su clínica de
rehabilitación los pacientes comenzaron
a hacer fila para verla el primer paso
es comprobar si hay fiebre después hay
que lavar las manos asumamos la mujer
estaba siendo tratada antes por una
simple lesión de rodilla pero ahora
tiene dificultad para respirar
nunca diagnosticada tenía síntomas
típicos de ccoo y 19 hace unos meses
tenía muchos dolores en el cuerpo no
comía nada nada en absoluto necesitaba
apoyo para poder caminar
mónica ha estado observando durante
meses que esos síntomas
a menudo persisten
dolor muscular debilidad dificultad para
respirar nadie habla de las secuelas del
cobi
nunca
he estado estudiando esto desde marzo
siempre supe que nos iba a golpear nadie
entra a las favelas nadie se ocupa de
ellas
120 pacientes con este tipo de efectos
secundarios están esperando ser tratados
mónica quiere crear un espacio dedicado
especialmente para ellos
este desde el espacio post cobit para la
gente de la favela
el centro médico de mónica sobrevive
gracias a las donaciones y las nuevas
reglas de seguridad vinculadas al
coronavirus han elevado los costos para
esta mujer con la enfermedad de
parkinson y muchas otras es su única
fuente de atención médica
todavía tiene problemas para respirar
creo que sería bueno llevarla al
hospital
desde la semana pasada los residentes de
esta favela están recibiendo pruebas
gratuitas hasta ahora una cuarta parte
de ellas han resultado positivas en
nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana la bbc
publicó este interesante artículo con el
que explica cómo la investigación para
el desarrollo de una vacuna contra el
kobe 19 podría generar una revolución en
la inmunización y en la forma como
funcionan las vacunas a través del uso
de la ingeniería genética de esta manera
las células podrían producir al ser
modificadas una parte del virus y así
enseñarle a nuestro sistema inmunológico
para protegernos de dicho virus el
artículo también indica que esto
permitiría crear vacunas más rápidos más
sencillas más seguras y más baratas
también fue noticia esta semana el
anuncio hecho por el laboratorio chino
sinovac que investiga una vacuna también
contra el kobe 19 y es considerada una
de las más avanzadas en su proceso de
desarrollo la directiva de esta
farmacéutica le indicó que la
inoculación masiva podría comenzar a
principios del 2021 al tiempo que
destacaron
en la capacidad de fabricar cerca de 300
millones de dosis al año pero hasta
tanto la vacuna no se ha desarrollado y
probada por completo con éxito hay que
guardar un poco de moderación con las
expectativas esta semana también la
compañía johnson y johnson indicó que
comenzó la última fase de ensayos
clínicos de su vacuna contra el cob y 19
así lo destacó la cadena alemana de w
que afirmó que esta propuesta de vacunas
era suministrada a unas 60.000 personas
voluntarias en varios países del mundo
que recibirán una dosis
johnson y johnson también afirmó que de
ser exitoso su desarrollo distribuirá la
vacuna sin tener beneficios económicos
la arquidiócesis de la ciudad de san
francisco en eeuu desafió a las
autoridades locales y convoco a cientos
de feligreses para marchar y exigir la
eliminación de los vetos que hay para
que puedan realizar los servicios
religiosos sin problemas
bajo el lema somos esenciales queremos
la misa a cientos de católicos marcharon
por las calles de san francisco para
exigir que reabran las iglesias y para
protestar contra lo que califican como
una discriminación hacia su fe y su vida
espiritual un mensaje que transformaron
en consigna haciéndose eco del
movimiento black life smarter y
resignificando lo bajo el renovado
spiritual life matters o la vida
espiritual importa venimos a protestar
la gran injusticia que se nos está
haciendo de qué lado nos dejan celebrar
la eucaristía y recibir el cuerpo y
sangre de cristo que es esencial para
nosotros domingo los manifestantes y las
autoridades eclesiásticas consideran que
las restricciones para celebrar misas
impuestas durante la pandemia de
coronavirus representan un trato injusto
hacia la iglesia frente a otros lugares
como peluquerías y tiendas el gobierno
de san francisco ha abierto
todas las todas las actividades todos
los negocios y todo y ha dejado a la
iglesia católica por último no nos
permiten sólo permiten 12 personas
afuera y ahora permitieron 50 después de
marcharse organizaron misas en varios
idiomas respetando la distancia social y
las medidas de bioseguridad de esta
manera los fieles continúan practicando
su fe un derecho que ven atacado por los
funcionarios locales que según ellos
ignoran sus peticiones durante estos
meses de pandemia la arquidiócesis de
san francisco y autoridades locales
atravesaron momentos de tensión en torno
a las restricciones para las casas de
culto incluso nancy pelosi presidenta de
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
entró en la polémica y le dijo al
arzobispo de san francisco que deberían
seguir a la ciencia así llegamos al
final de kobe 19 la semana en américa
muchas gracias por su sintonía buen fin
de semana para todos
[Música]